Você sabia que aquele adoçante que você
usa todo dia pode estar envelhecendo o
seu cérebro mais rápido? Pois é, acabou
de sair um estudo brasileiro bem
interessante sobre isso. Olha só que os
pesquisadores descobriram na revista
Neurology. Quem consome muito adoçante
artificial tem 62% mais chance de ter
declínio cognitivo acelerado. Isso
equivale a um envelhecimento cerebral de
1,6 anos a mais. Então, estamos falando
de aspartamâina, acesulfâia, ritritol,
sorbitol, chilitol, essas substâncias
que a gente acha que são inofensivas.
Veja bem, o problema não é usar de vez
em quando, mas sim um consumo diário
excessivo. Então, esses compostos podem
interferir na microbiota intestinal e
nos processos inflamatórios cerebrais,
acelerando o que a gente chama de
neuroenvelhecimento. É como se o cérebro
perdesse sua capacidade de se manter
jovem e funcional. Será que vale a pena
trocar açúcar por adoçante pensando que
estamos nos protegendo? Talvez seja a
hora de repensar essa estratégia e
buscar alternativas mais naturais, ou
pelo menos usar com muito mais
moderação.